when you get your first movie dazed and
confused i mean your first big thing and
the movie was a big movie you like just
kind of decided to be an actor because
you meet some guy in a bar who's a
casting director right where was the bar
austin texas on uh i think was down on
first street and you're sitting here
what are you having a beer or something
i'm there with my girlfriend order a
drink i'm there because the bartender
was in film school with me not acting
school but problems could he give me
free drinks yeah you want to be a
director right that was your sort of
focus at that point yeah behind the
camera yeah maybe i'll be behind the
camera or whatever and then you're
sitting there and some casting director
dude comes up to you and says hey you're
a good-looking dude well guys bartender
says the guy at the the end of the uh
bars in town producing the film so i go
introduce myself right name is don
phillips what'd you say to don phillips
i said i introduced myself and i said
you're in town working on a film and he
goes yeah yeah i'm working on this film
producing i'm casting it's called days
confused what do you want so he was kind
of off putting together some kind of
like stupid what do you want so
we started shooting the [ __ ] and all of
a sudden we we both knew we played golf
we had a similar course we had played
cut to three hours later we get kicked
out right um forbidden little
rambunctious and on the ride home in the
taxi he says hey matt matthew you ever
done any acting
and he got acting he's never done any
acting if you know don phillips people
out there go this is what he said it was
like and he's and i said well i was in a
middle light commercial for about that
long yeah let's say it was more of a
modeling job for a half a second right
he goes well come to this address in the
morning if you're interested you might
be just right for this part i go down
pick up the script the day's confused
yeah and uh richard linklater was the
director
and so he meets with you right i go home
there's three lines i go home and back
to longview texas and work on these
three lines for three weeks what were
the three lines you even remember well
one
one is a great line the long i call it a
launch pad line right where you get a
line like this and you go oh there's a
there's a whole [ __ ] book on this
character
and it's a guy it's wooderson out front
of the pool hall the girls walk by he
reaches over he slaps one on the back
side as she passes and his buddy says
you're going to go to jail for that you
got to cut that out and he says no man
high school
i keep getting older but they say the
same age
you get a line like that philosopher
whoa yeah you know genius so as soon as
i get that line i'm like who is this cat
right and you know you could write a
book on somebody if they believe that
and so i ended up working three weeks
yeah but when you got the interview with
this guy link later he says to you hey
you're not this guy
yeah so i come in
and it's a job interview right so i
shave i do my hair i i
iron my shirt gotta have a pleat in my
jeans tucked in and everything and i'm
gonna go back my
yeah
i walk in he's like
yeah you're here to read for wooderson
i'm like yes sir and he's like
okay well then i sat down and this rick
tales he said i sat in the chair and he
goes okay go ahead and he said i kind of
just kicked back and laid my shoulders
back and did worse and he comes and goes
well you're not this guy i said no i'm
not this guy but i know who this guy is
right and it's who i thought my middle
brother was
when i was 11 and he was 17. uh-huh and
it was through the back window of my
mom's car going to pick him up from
school one day because his car was broke
down and she's looking for him outside
the school and he's not there he's
supposed to be
well i see him at the back window
leaning against the wall
knee out foot up against the wall
smoking a cigarette in the smoking
section that's the guy he was seven f he
was the coolest right and and i go there
he and i remember shutting up because
he'd got his ass beat for smoking right
i didn't tell mom there he was but that
image has been pulled away watching my
brother so in other words only in acting
should you not walk in for your job
interview all cleanly shaved and groomed
when i walked away did you have a
briefcase yeah yeah yeah yeah i really
did yeah probably board
a pen recorder but what a break to get
that yeah and uh did your dad live long
enough to see you uh have some success
cool thing about my dad's passing the
timing um
he moved on five days into
me working on days confused
so he didn't come see it but he was
alive for me to do
what turned out to be my career right
which there's i got some some nice peace
in that because everything before that
was a hobby you mean your dad got to see
you get a job on dazed and confused got
to see me get a job that turned out to
be my career did you think uh davison
confused was going to be a big movie i
had no idea i i was they're paying me
325 bucks a day people were inviting me
back the next day telling me i'm good at
it the most i had made was 72 bucks
waiting tables at catfish station since
teach me something about acting
when you prepared for that movie dazed
and confused they say you listened to
live doors music jim morrison uh
specifically and jim morrison said all
right all right all right like probably
from one of the stage announcements and
so how does that get you in touch with
your character because all right all
right or write sounds like something no
no no not that literal at all number one
link letter on that film what he did his
first piece of direction was he handed
every character a cassette
with the mixtape of music he goes this
is what i think you gotta be listening
to well as a young actor
you're getting handed badass music on a
cassette to go rock out to and that's
your homework yeah okay so you listen to
it so that song in particular i did not
remember this is something there's some
i think it's a live album in like
copenhagen or something and morris is
like all right all right all right all
right he barks it out like four times
[Music]
[Applause]
i'm not thinking of that but on the
night
where i would i go to do a scene i'm not
i wasn't supposed to do a scene rick
just says hey i got this idea maybe
wooderson's picking up on the redheaded
intellectual what do you think i said
sure he goes you want to shoot it i'm
like okay so i go get in my car now i'm
getting nervous first thing i've ever
done it's not scripted so i'm telling
myself my head who's my man who's my man
who's wooderson what am i and i go well
what am i about i said i'm about my car
yeah i go well i'm in my 70s chevelle i
said i'm about getting high i said well
slater's writing shotgun he's got a
dubois rolled up right i said i'm about
rock and roll there we go we got ted
nugent stranglehold in the eight track
and i hear action
and so i look up and in my head i go
well the fourth thing i'm about
is chicks
and that's what i'm about to go pick up
and in my mind i said well you got three
out of four
all right all right all right and that
was me confirming
out loud the three things i got and i'm
gonna go get the fourth so the line was
all right all right all right all right
all right all right
how you doing
that's the first words i ever said on
film wow first words ever said kind of
stuck too right when people do
impressions and stuff he's like all
right all right it did kind of stick and
i don't mind